hi in this video we are going to talk
about vitamin K vitamin K is mostly
obtained from leafy vegetables and the
dietary intake range is 70 to 140
microgram per day there are three forms
of vitamin K phylloquinone or known as
vitamin k1 which is enriched in leafy
vegetables vitamin k2 or medically known
which is also present in leafy
vegetables and dairy product and a
synthetic form which is known as Menand
ion which is vitamin K 3 as I mentioned
that the key source for vitamin K is
leafy green vegetables now let's look at
what is the process of absorption of
vitamin K in the intestine let's say we
just ate a bowl of salad filled up with
leafy greens and let's look at our
intestine what happens and how the
absorption takes place so in fact the
intestine vitamin K would be absorbed
with the lipid my sillies in the
lymphatic system because it's a fat
soluble hormones right fat soluble
vitamin now after getting absorbed it is
important to understand that what is the
role of vitamin K vitamin K plays
crucial role in blood clotting and blood
clotting takes place with a clotting
factor cascade which forms a meshwork
like structure and forms the clot and
the T clotting factors which takes part
in this process are actually synthesized
by vitamin K or vitamin K takes an
important role in the in their synthetic
synthesis process the clotting factors
that are dependent on vitamin K is
clotting factor 2 or performing then
clotting factor 7 9 and 10 so all of
these help in blood clotting so it could
be understand it could be understood
that whenever you have an injury and
there is a
blood loss if you have deficiency in
vitamin K then the bleeding time would
be increased right and this is due to
the problem in proton main synthesis
because the proton main synthesis
requires an enzyme gama glutamine
carboxylase which carboxylate the
glutamate residues in the inactive form
now after carboxylation proton means
proton main get activated and this is
done by vitamin k vitamin k works like a
coenzyme for gamma glutamine carboxylase
and this is how this process is
augmented by vitamin K now the
deficiency could be due to many reason
for example absorption defect in the
intestine or due to prolong consumption
of antibiotics which kill all the gut
microflora and guide gut microflora
plays a key role in absorption not only
in adults in infants vitamin K
deficiency could occur because in infant
the Guttman intestine is relatively
sterile and it doesn't have that much of
gut microflora as a result the vitamin
k1 absorption could be deficient so for
infant hemorrhage or infant blood clots
it is recommended intramuscular
injection of vitamin k and it is all
about this video I hope this video was
useful if you liked this video give it a
big thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you